next on public lives brian lebeau
discusses the atheist madeleine murray
o'hare it's a biography of the woman who
founded the american atheists this talk
runs about an hour
welcome to the c-span crew nice to have
you with us and welcome to all of you
pleased you could join us and that you
have some interest in this really
fascinating woman
uh to whom i hope i can do some justice
tonight what a wonderful setting to be
at unity temple
devoted to all faiths
multi-denominational
to be talking about a woman who offended
all faiths
so there's some irony in that but it's a
wonderful setting
as well
in the rather short time i have to cover
this woman's rather fascinating life i
thought i would focus in essentially on
five questions the first is really about
me that will be brief and the other for
perhaps a little longer first of all how
did i come to write this book about
madeline murray o'hare
secondly who was she because most people
know the name but they get a little
confused as to what exactly she did
why did she do
what she did which became very important
to me in my research
what was life like for madeleine mario
here after her most shining moment on in
1963
and then how did she die a faith that is
still
somewhat unclear in the minds of of many
people
so let's begin with that and start first
of all by answering how i came to write
this book
i'm a historian of american culture
and my various books have dealt with
art and literature
public memory and religion which i've
written quite a bit my interest in
religion is really less about belief and
doctrine and church teachings than it
really is on religion as a phenomenon in
american society
i always found it fascinating to study a
society that takes such great pride on
its provisions in the first amendment
for the separation of church and state
and that rejects theocracy of all forms
at home and abroad
but by most measures percentages of
people who believe in god who belong to
particular churches who attend church
regularly who believe that god plays a
major role in their lives is one of the
most religious nations
on earth indeed i think we could make
the case perhaps on another night uh
that really belief in god and the
special relationship between god in the
united states
really a civil religion has been part of
the american psyche or identity
from its very founding
and i think you can see it
reflections of it in presidential
rhetoric and phrases such as one nation
under god and our pledge of allegiance
our national motto and god we trust and
so much more
what attracted me to madeline muriel
here in particular was my interest in
the place of atheism non-belief unbelief
in such a nation in particular the role
of atheism in the united states at a
time period where religion was actually
at its peak when fervor was most intense
during the early cold war the period of
late 40s 1950s and early 1960s when uh
not only were more americans engaged and
espoused and uh in believing in
organized religion than any other period
but also when our mortal enemy abroad at
home was atheistic communism and we
defined ourselves largely in terms as
being quite the opposite free and
religious so that led me to study
madeline murray o'hare it's kind of the
example the epitome of atheism in this
particular time period
so who is madeline murray o'hare on
december 8 1960 madeleine murray not yet
o'hare
filed suit in the superior court of
baltimore maryland asking the court to
rule required bible reading and
recitation of the lord's prayer in the
city's public schools unconstitutional
she claimed that her son william's first
amendment rights were being violated
that he was being discriminated against
because he when he refused
to participate in the school's morning
religious exercise he was alienated or
isolated from his fellow students
defeated in the lower courts madeleine
appeared what became murray vikralet to
the united states supreme court where it
was joined with a similar case out of
pennsylvania shemp versus school
district of abington township
and on june 17th 1963 the court found in
favor of the murrays and the schemes by
a margin of eight to one declared that
the maryland and pennsylvania laws
violated the establishment clause of the
first amendment effectively removing
organized teacher-led prayer from the
public schools
although this didn't occur in a vacuum
indeed there were several cases that led
up to this one the year before ingol
vitali in 1962
nevertheless much of the nation was
really quite stunned and angry but
whereas the ships who had taken a low
profile throughout the case shunned the
limelight murray seized it she took
credit for having single-handedly banned
bible reading and prayer from the
nation's public schools
she overstated the case but americans
searching for someone to blame were only
too willing to accept her claim
when she chose to become the leading
proponent of atheism or opponent of
religion whichever you prefer she became
not only the most visible of american
atheists but she also became as the
press quickly branded her the most hated
woman in america
the details of madeleine murray's life
who upon her second marriage in 1968
became madeline murray o'hare
are fascinating but equally interesting
i think is how americans responded to
her
similarly her ideas on religion are
interesting but no more so than how
those ideas related to american culture
from the cold war to the end of the
century
as her son william who later broke with
her
over her atheist activities wrote and i
think he was at least partly correct
in reality my mother did not create the
time the time created her madeline
murray o'hare struggled against the
cultural and political consensus on many
subjects especially religion
not being content to personally and
quietly reject the idea of belief in god
she launched a crusade against it
now important point here i think we need
to make if you have any
memory of madeline muriel here is in
contrast to how the press and i think
her enemies portrayed her madeline
murray o'hare was really quite
intelligent and well educated both
formally and informally especially for
the time in which she grew up
yes she was crude
she was vulgar
her use of foul language shocked people
but her message was always accessible to
even those with just a minimal education
and she made very effective use of the
media
by her personal behavior
somewhat exaggerated by the enemies her
enemies and the press she personified
really what people expected of atheists
she fulfilled americans expectations of
what would happen if someone were to
lose his or her faith in god
in her hands atheism was no longer
exclusively a matter of scholarly debate
or hushed acceptance among fringe groups
o'hare placed it near the top of
america's public agenda where her
enemies maintained it threatened to
subvert debase and pervert all that was
holy or good in american life
now again to understand this we have to
put it in the context in which she was
popular coming of the cold war witnessed
the campaign against international
communism the fact that the soviet union
was not just a military foe but a nation
committed to communism and atheism posed
a unique challenge to the united states
american anti-communists insisted that
communism was not only opposed to
religion but also the natural enemy of
religion and those countries founded on
belief in god
thus communism popularly branded
atheistic communism became anti-american
as well and the united states became a
bulwark against it at home and abroad
this added to the urgency of the battle
against atheism as one observer pointed
out whenever their opponents began
railing against those atheists the
latter ceased to be individuals who
mattered to god
instead they became quote a monolithic
mass of faceless enemies and in a war
there's no fraternizing with the other
side
the hunt for atheistic communists was on
and to underscore it in 1954 congress
added the phrase under god to the pledge
of allegiance signing the law on flag
day june 14 1954 president dwight
eisenhower praised the addition for
reaffirming the transcendence of
religious faith in american heritage and
future
on july 11 1955 he signed a federal law
which required in god we trust on the
nation's currency
on july 30th 1956 he made it the
national motto
on july 4th 1953 eisenhower and vice
president nixon launched the march of
freedom a movement intended to affirm
america's spiritual heritage and the
divine basis of its freedom
in 1955 eisenhower told the nation
recognition of the supreme being is the
first the most basic expression of
americanism without god there could be
no american form of government nor any
american way of life
and this continued through the fifties
and into the early sixties
o'hare protested that she wasn't a
communist at one point in her life she
actually did grow fairly close to the
movement subscribed to elements and
communist ideology but ultimately she
renounced her ties to communism
but even if she had no involvement with
the movement she would have she could
not have escaped the label anyway when
she stepped into the national limelight
as an atheist most americans could not
help but see her as a communist as well
and therefore a national threat
similarly atheism and immorality were
linked cold war americans believe that
be a more to be a moral person you had
to be religious
probably christian
therefore americans associated o'hare
with what they saw as the growing
immorality of post-war america and her
private life confirmed that association
in the minds of many this person's
denial of god has opened the door to a
selfish vulgar and often immoral
lifestyle
wrote one observer words like liar
cheater hypocrite publicity seeker only
scratched the surface in describing this
individual's depth of personal
corruption
for many americans o'hare was proof that
the arch enemy was real
and in their midst
as i'll show in a moment madeline mayor
madeleine murray-o'hare
was no angel she violated some of the
nation's most sacred codes of behavior
but she didn't have to put her
transgressions on display for the nation
to see
others shared her beliefs and engaged in
the same socially unacceptable behavior
but they chose to do so quietly
out of the limelight
o'hare seized the moment claimed full
responsibility and challenged the
believing public to contend with her
i'm more than an atheist
i'm in fact the atheist wrote madeline
muriel here
in 1965 playboy magazine asked madeline
for a crusade to separate church and
state was her raison d'etre she replied
that it was only one expression of her
raison d'etre she was an atheist but she
was also an anarchist a feminist an
integrationist internationalist all the
otherists that people seem to find so
horrible today i embraced them all
the public response to a hair may best
be described as a firestorm and as even
one of her critics was forced to admit
he had never seen anyone with such a
breathtaking willingness to endure
public hatred
but why did she do this why did she so
willingly assume such a persona as one
critic puzzled she thoroughly
personified the christian stereotype of
an atheist rude impertinent blasphemous
a destroyer not only of beliefs but also
of esteemed values
she popped off like a chain of fireworks
in a sanctuary merrily detonating
everything we hold dear it was
impossible not to admire her nerve while
at the same time wondering at her
apparent in compulsion to be loathed
was she simply committed to changing the
world to making it by her way of
thinking a better more humane place
not entirely there were some personal
reasons for her behavior as well and
that takes us back really to her early
life and i would say that one thing that
really helped me through this is i was
the first
other than a few newspaper people to
actually have access to her diaries
which really did open up a whole new
area of this exploration
madeline was born madeline evelyn mays
on april 13 1919 in pittsburgh
pennsylvania madeleine recalled i don't
believe there could have been a happier
or more secure childhood than mine
she described her mother is beautiful
her father is a knight in shining armor
in her life as growing up amidst
affluence typically the account was
exaggerated but madeleine did live a
comfortable life as a child at least
until the great depression when the
stock market crash destroyed her
father's business
and then for the next several years the
family moved from place to place while
john mays sought work and money to
support his wife and children
madeleine often referred to those years
in their influence on her later life if
once prosperous and carefree that was no
longer the case moreover by her telling
the hardship she suffered bored the
seeds of her later rejection of god her
father was presbyterian her mother was
lutheran her parents baptized madeleine
the presbyterian church at the age of
four and she attended church on and
sunday school
somewhat irregularly
then at the age of 12 or 13 as madeleine
tells it while in the sixth grade and
living in akron ohio madeleine read the
bible
she read it cover to cover in one
weekend she later reported and quote
realized it was a perfectly bizarre book
she was completely appalled totally
turned off and filled with repugnance by
what she discovered i came away stunned
with the hatred the brutality the
sadomasochism the cruelty the killing
the ugliness
at about the same time while attending
church she began to take note of the
ministers accusing his flock of being
full of sin though he never explained
why instead they passed a collection
plate and i got in my mind that this had
to do with the purification of the soul
that we were being invited to buy
expiation for our sins so i gave it all
up it was too nonsensical
the mays were not enthusiastic
churchgoers as i mentioned earlier
nevertheless when madeline explained her
conclusions concerning the bible to her
parents and read them the offending
passages her mother simply drew herself
up and responded that's not my bible
madeleine was not to be dissuaded
however i never accepted the bible after
that day i refused to go to sunday
school anymore and i refused to go to
church
the mays family may have been poor as a
result of the depression but in 1936
madeleine was able to spend one year at
the university of toledo
in
1938-39 she enrolled at the university
of pittsburgh
when the family returned to that city
but she did not graduate instead on
october 9 1941 at age 22 she eloped with
john henry roths a steel worker a local
guy who madeline had met in high school
two months later the roth's marriage was
disrupted by american involvement in
world war ii
both enlisted
but received separate assignments
he became a marine and was sent to the
pacific she enlisted in the women's
auxiliary army corps and was
commissioned as a second lieutenant she
served on the cryptographic staff in the
super supreme allied headquarters in
north africa france and italy while
stationed in italy lieutenant madeleine
roths met and conceived a child with
william murray jr an officer in the u.s
eighth army corps
according to their sons william when
madeleine returned her son william when
madeleine returned home from the war her
parents were living in a shack with no
electricity or running water her father
had spent on booze all the money she had
sent for savings the family was
destitute
she was pregnant
when roth returned he offered to stay
with his wife and raise the child as his
own but o'hare declined and proceeded to
sue for divorce according to madeleine
murray refute murray the father of the
child refused to leave his wife because
he was a catholic and opposed to divorce
but he actually denied he was the father
forcing madeleine to establish his
paternity in court in order to receive
child support
although william murray's refusal to
divorce his wife cannot be ascribed then
solely to his being a catholic
his son concluded that it provoked and
his mother's antagonism toward roman
catholicism which was always her prime
enemy uh and god the latter symbolized
by one of the most dramatic episodes in
madeleine's life
one night in early 1946 during a violent
electrical storm madeleine still
pregnant and in despair announced that
she was going out in the storm to
challenge god to strike her and her
unborn child dead with lightning bolts
she stood in the rain
waving her fist
cursing god and when nothing happened
shirt went back into the house and said
you see if god exists he would surely
have taken up my challenge
i've proved irrefutably that god does
not exist
madeleine attempted to rebuild her life
she graduated from ashland college in
1948 and from south texas school of law
in 1952.
in 1952 john may's sister-in-law invited
him to join her family's business
in baltimore maryland they bought a
small brick row house at 1526 winford
road in a quiet middle class
neighborhood and madeleine began her
diary in which she voiced some guarded
optimism for the future
on january 5th 1953 as her first entry
she wrote the year has the look and the
feel of a good one well paced eventful
prosperous
she nevertheless listed several issues
that gave her pause and even presented a
dismal foundation on which to build so
she wrote to begin with she found that
the maryland bar examiners did not
recognize her law degree because south
texas law school had not yet been
accredited so she couldn't take the bar
exam
second the family continued to be in
financial difficulties
madeleine reported that her former
employer had written a condemning note
to the pub to the public department of
public welfare for whom she wanted to
work and that she had been forced to
take a job at the glenell martin company
instead she hated the job
and as months passed even this level of
madeleine's optimism slowly waned and
her frustration grew the family's
financial situation improved only
slightly and she felt trapped by her job
and frustrated by her life she observed
in her diary i don't like these row
houses nests of bees identical homes
with identical people and identical
lives yet truly i long to be part of
society
i would like to have a routine humdrum
existence or so i've thought
a set of contradictions if there ever
was one
madeleine had moments of renewed
optimism and satisfaction but generally
the remaining years of the decade as
reflected in her diary were marred by
even greater despair and anger both with
herself and the world around her
she condemned her own laziness and
mistakes but she also condemned the
society in which she lived
for the situation in which she found
herself at that point on may 16 1953 she
confided to her diary there's nothing
for me ahead but a petty existence eked
out from day to day i'm frustrated and
bitter and full of hate
madeleine also commented on world and
national events again in an increasingly
critical manner she grew highly critical
of joseph mccarthy richard nixon and the
anti-communist movement she joined
americans for democratic action then the
socialist labor party and then the
socialist workers party
madeleine became an early proponent of
feminism and an opponent of french and
american involvement in vietnam she
opposed the korean war the testing of
nuclear weapons in the atmosphere and
suppression of the rights of algerians
and black south
africans and a proponent of improving
the lot of migrant workers
but madeline couldn't live by politics
alone on july 3 1953 she wrote in her
diary i need to unlock again my emotions
i need to love
i've been pent up and hard and cynical
too long
i need to be a woman
soon thereafter madeleine began seeing
michael fiorillo from new york city whom
she met at work she converted to her
diary that she felt like a high school
girl again
he folded me into his arms and naturally
and completely kissed me like i have
wanted to be kissed for 20 years i was
so absolutely pleased and surprised
i almost got kidnish interesting image
from madeleine o'hare
on november 16 1954 madeleine gave birth
to her second out of wedlock child whom
she married john garth murray after the
father of her first son
fiorillo challenged his paternity
of john garth but lost
again i would remind you this is the
1950s
madeleine also ruminated about her
social situation i say i have bad luck
but don't we make our luck
isn't it a combination of poor judgment
and indiscretion
then there's a pause and a very key
transition i don't really believe that
why do i write it i see social remorse
that are wrong stupid and immoral the
people who live by the moors see me as a
flagrant violator an extremist something
foreign to them and dangerous
by the early months of 1955 madeleine
hit absolute bottom but she refused to
be counted out as there was no place to
go but up
she attacked the moral code inculcated
in school church and other institutions
she explained that she ignored the code
completely and lived by raw rules that
discussed revolt and injure
everyone is playing a horrible game of
lip service versus the darkest and most
cruel conduct in dead earnestness it's
macabre and hysterically funny these
dark games are dangerous and men die for
false ideals and distorted truths and
will forever and ever
amen
the question she continued was how to
resolve yourself to this insane
situation the answer she suggested to
reject it indeed to topple it
consequently i will be ostracized she
wrote by my own volition from society
henceforth and since i've decided i'm
rather happy about it
although she would waver in her
commitment from time to time madeleine
was committed to a life of confrontation
with american society what she needed
was a cause
madeleine might have committed herself
to any number of causes her feminism
nuclear disarmament social reform
political activism
atheism was neither her only nor even
really at this point her primary concern
as the decade drew to a close madeline
contemplated
how she would sort of translate this
into an action against the world and she
began to think about first of all
leaving the country she thought about
renouncing her citizenship and even the
possibility of defecting to the soviet
union but she abandoned that idea and
resolved the focuser energy on reforming
the united states
that idea and she then decided she would
enroll at howard university a
traditionally black institution seeking
a master's degree in psychiatric work
but she was expelled after
quarreling with her advisor
madeline found a job in the social
security administration
but was fired
and during the spring and summer of 1959
for about three months she moved into an
apartment with a man called ricardo she
left her sons in the care of her parents
admitted that her family wasn't happy
with their decision she hoped all would
be reconciled in time but the
relationship failed and she moved back
home again
this is when she took on the baltimore
public schools
when they moved to baltimore madeleine
enrolled william in park school a
private school
and then which then moved to west
baltimore and william had to commute to
the school after a semester of an
exhausting long commute and a struggle
to meet the tuition bills she decided to
switch him to the local public school
william later recalled that as they
passed through the halls of woodbourne
junior high his mother was perturbed to
see the students standing and pledging
allegiance to the flag and angry when
she observed them bowing their head and
reciting the lord's prayer
upon entering the counselor's office
madeleine confronted the man who greeted
her asking why the students were praying
it's un-american it's unconstitutional
she proclaimed and let him know that she
did not want her son to be taught any
prayers
the man was clearly flustered by
madeleine's charge and at first
responded by noting that nobody else had
ever complained and that even those who
were not very religious thought prayer
recitation set a nice tone for the day
after he regained his composure he added
there were prayers in the school of the
city before there was a united states of
america if our forefathers had wanted us
to stop this practice they would have
told us that when they formed this
government
his response infuriated madeleine he
probably should have stopped there
she informed the counselor that people
like him had to be stopped whereupon he
replied then why don't you sue us
he could not have anticipated what he
had suggested to be sure
on october 27 1960
the face of william murray graced page
one of the baltimore morning sun beneath
the headline boy 14 box at bible reading
the three column article reported the
facts of the case the murray's position
and that this was the first reported
challenge to the baltimore school
board's rule on prayer since its
adoption in 1905.
telephone calls began immediately first
from local reporters the national
reporters all seeking interviews
on november 2nd 1960 maryland attorney
general c ferdinand seibert ruled that
objections to exercise exercises were
not a valid reason for non-compliance
with the public school law and that
anyone who absented himself from school
to avoid them could be prosecuted for
truancy
cybert recommended that pupils who
objected to bible reading or school
prayer be allowed to remain silent upon
the written request of their parents or
be excused from the exercise he
acknowledged that such non-conformity
would cause individual embarrassment but
that was the price to be paid for
non-conformity
now there was a little bit for everybody
in this ruling uh the morning religious
exercises remain but the murrays won the
right to absent william from it
madeleine however viewed the decision as
almost total victory for the school
board and would not compromise she
pressed on the murray's attorney filed a
petition for a writ of mandamus on
december 8th 1960 in the superior court
of baltimore the case initially called
william j murray the third versus
baltimore school board became murray v
curlett curlett being the school board
president on april 27 1961 judge gilbert
pendergast
dismissed the murray's petition and the
murrays appealed the decision to the
maryland court of appeals and that court
ruled against the murrays as well and
finally the murrays appealed the court
to the united the case to the united
states supreme court or it was joined
with shemp the case i mentioned earlier
which came out of pennsylvania where the
state court actually ruled that the
state law was unconstitutional so it was
an interesting joining of cases
on june 17th 1963 the u.s supreme court
returned the murray and shemp cases the
court declared unconstitutional the
maryland and pennsylvania laws requiring
bible reading and prayer recitation in
the public schools because they violated
the establishment clause of the first
amendment the majority opinion
maintained that the establishment clause
is violated by any government
sponsorship of religion in the public
schools regardless of whether a showing
of coercion exists
this was a reference to the letting yeah
william have the opportunity to leave
the room as justice tom
clark put it for a law to be valid there
must be a secular legislative purpose
and a primary effect that neither
advances nor inhibits religion and the
maryland and pennsylvania laws fail that
test
madeleine murray felt vindicated by the
decision and she best in the sunlight of
public and media attention she vowed to
go beyond removing prayer and bible
reading from the nation's public schools
but has it been the case throughout her
adult life she was not without her
personal second thoughts she continually
struggled to understand herself and her
seemingly uncontrollable need to
challenge and change some of the most
dearly held beliefs in the world around
her several years after the cases were
decided she described one such
contemplated contemplative moment
one evening in baltimore she as she sat
alone in her basement library trying to
decide whether to press ahead with a
lawsuit madam reflected on her sense of
separateness
when we first moved into those row
houses in baltimore she wrote i think i
had picked out one for purchase
deliberately in the hopes that i could
be like everyone else
i had wanted so desperately to fit in
but i could not engage in conversation
about which bleach was the whitest for
the wash
i never gave a dam about chlorophyll and
toothpaste the idiotic idea of back
fence visiting left me completely cold
she acknowledged that none of her work
had ever fully occupied her mind and
thinking processes and that out of
frustration she would too often pace the
basement library floor like a lioness
caged the wrap of loneliness of
aloneness always around me i just wanted
one person somewhere sometime to
understand me
it's been argued that the singular
importance of murray v curlett was the
involvement of madeleine murray who
seized the opportunity to attain
national notoriety as the leader of the
american atheist movement when the
newspapers reported on the murray shemp
decision
madeline william and john garth were
pictured standing on the steps of the
u.s supreme court building the shems
were nowhere to be found
soon every newspaper magazine and radio
and television commentator in the land
referred to her as the woman who brought
the case that removed prayer and bible
reading from the schools and madeleine
resented any attempt to limit her
responsibility in those cases she laid
claim to being the primary figure in the
1963 supreme court decision by arguing
that edward shemp in his failure to
seize the moment and lead the movement
for separation of church and state
forfeited that role
forty years after she initiated the case
four years after her mysterious
disappearance the washington post made
the point that the murrays were neither
the only plaintiffs involved in the 63
supreme court ruling but they weren't
even essential
madeleine however it added was the
litigant with the loudest mouth and it
made her a celebrity
one of the earliest major published
exposes on madeleine murray appeared in
life magazine in 1964. life used as its
title the most hated woman in america
making it household currency author jane
howard described madeleine as america's
most outspoken and militant atheist her
cause was the total and utter separation
of church and state and a land where
most people believe in god and those who
don't keep quiet howard wrote such a
cause is as good a way to win public
favor as bringing back polio
murray she added which outlawed official
prayer ceremonies in public schools and
made the name of murray anethema to
millions of americans madeleine agreed
with howard's assessment and made note
of the death threats she had received
madeleine said that she loved life but
that she simply had to fight which she
knew in her guts was wrong she quipped i
think sooner or later some night some
nuts going to get a message from jesus
christ and i'm going to have had it but
as long as i'm still around i'm going to
keep on being a squeaking wheel
now i don't have time to go into her
life after murray in any great detail
but let me just comment on it briefly
because i think it's important
madeleine murray issued her challenge to
the baltimore public schools during the
cold war this helps explain the public
reaction to her protest against prayer
in the public schools and the outrage at
her success
indeed although it made her the most
hated woman in america it also made her
one of the best known
and it gave her a cause that would serve
her well
during the quite different reform-minded
counter-cultural even iconoclastic late
1960s and 1970s it was during those
years that madeline murray o'hare as
head of american atheist in society for
the separation of church and state
reached her peak of popularity and
influence
she and her organizations challenge the
words under god and the pledge of
allegiance
in god we trust on american currency the
tax-exempt status of religious
organizations
the use of chaplains in the military and
open sessions of government
the pope's performance of mass on the
washington mall
u.s astronauts reading the bible in
space
and much more the list goes on she lost
most of her cases but as she readily
admitted she never expected to win
at least in the short run what she
sought was to make cases for what she
saw as violations of constitutional
provisions for the separation of church
and state
and the rights of atheists as well as
what she saw as the destructive
oppressive power of religion in america
in the most visible manner to educate
americans really on these matters for
the future she believed that although a
fervent minority believed in and
defended this unofficial de facto
establishment of religion most did not
or didn't care
not seeing the danger of it and
therefore could be persuaded to oppose
it and for a time during the 1960s and
70s o'hare was one of the most visible
reformers in america
she was on every major tv and radio talk
show her face was on the cover of every
leading magazine her actions were
covered regularly in the press the fbi
had a file on her when i wrote that i
realized but they had a file on
everybody so that wasn't any great
accomplishment
death war death threats against her were
a common occurrence and she often had to
be hustled away under guard when her
public remarks incited crowds to
menacing levels
but then the times changed again the
cold war reheated during the reagan
years complete with renewed ideological
crusades against the evil empire and
turning a cold shoulder to liberals
reformers and those standing outside the
new ideological mainstream
the more conservative mood of the nation
the fact that much of what people found
so shocking and appealing about o'hare
and her cause during the previous
decades became old hat
and the errors made on her own part all
precipitated o'hare's gradual decline
o'hare roared in opposition to the
reagan decade but she was tilting with
windmills especially when those to whom
she once appealed tired of the battle
for liberal reform it might well have
been heard to respond madeleine we've
heard it before
as o'hare lived into her mid-60s and
once again faced issues she thought long
ago resolved she increasingly despaired
and spoke of ill health and being
exhausted she rallied at times in
challenging the new christian right and
allied forces mustered to drag the
nation back into the dark ages as she
saw it
but then her son william murray in whose
name she brought the case defected was
born again and became her enemy
the press had a field day with the turn
of events and its coverage of american
atheist activities was limited to
periodic confrontations between the two
groups portrayed much like the carnival
will come to town complete with
sideshows and other attractions at which
to marvel or laugh but certainly not to
take seriously
as o'hair prepared to retire her
american atheist faced its most serious
challenge since its inception when
o'hare rose to prominence attracted
people she attracted people to her and
expanded her operation
she also became increasingly dictatorial
she had no patience with those of lesser
skills in energy or who challenged or
even questioned her and as a result she
alienated many of those who might have
served
her organization well
this was not a significant problem as
long as she had the limelight it became
a problem as she lost that prominence
and members of her own organization
began to blame her for the decline of
the movement and sought to remove her
from power
others simply sensed no doubt her
growing weakness and moved in for the
kill for their own reasons
trusting no one beyond her immediate
circle o'hare insisted on passing the
baton to her son
john garth murray his leadership and
interpersonal skills were questionable
and the method by which he was thrust
into power outraged many within the
national organization
combined with its mounting financial
problems on the uh on the eve of
madeleine john and robin murray's
disappearance in 1995 american atheists
seemed on the verge of being torn apart
if not collapsing altogether
but madeline murray o'hare's life ended
on a much more bizarre note on august 28
1995 madeleine john and robin murray
robin was madeline's granddaughter who
was actually william's daughter
estranged
disappeared
speculation arose that madeleine had
died and that john and robin had
secreted her body away for cremation and
burial out of the public eye as
madeleine had requested some believe
that the trio had fled the country due
to their financial problems absconding
with whatever organization monies
remained this interpretation stuck by
the way i just got off the net there's a
production opening in new york at the
wash and fold theater project
i'm from new york that's a new one on me
and it's called the last days of
madeleine murray o'hare in exile and
what it has is madeline muriel here
absconding with the money living on a
south sea island and going through sort
of re rethinking her whole life so this
this interpretation appealed to a lot of
people
and of course a few thought they had
been murdered by some by some irate
chryster as she put it who madeline
predicted all along would kill her
indeed the trio had been murdered but
not by a chrysler instead they were
killed by an ex-con
and former employee who madeline once
charged with theft of organization funds
david waters entered a plea of guilty in
that case in exchange for probation and
was ordered to make restitution
he also vowed revenge a vow he kept
waters and two accomplices abducted the
trio forced them to withdraw over five
hundred thousand dollars from the
organization's bank accounts killed them
dismembered their bodies and buried them
in shallow graves outside san antonio
texas
in january 2001 waters once again in a
plea bargain led authorities to those
graves where the remains were recovered
william murray claimed and buried them
without prayer in an undisclosed
location in the hills near austin
well let me conclude by just talking a
little bit about madeleine's legacy
she's gone but certainly not forgotten
or at least her legacy continues to
challenge us to this day
many americans still refusing to accept
the supreme court's ruling and murray
continue to seek creative and
constitutionally acceptable ways around
that decision
and other challenges that madeleine
brought but failed to win continue to be
brought up the most recent being the
case brought by michael newdow on behalf
of his eight-year-old daughter to the
ninth u.s circuit court of appeals in
san francisco which resulted in a ruling
that the words under god were
unconstitutional when uttered by
teachers leading school children in
their morning exercises
in the midst of dying telecoms charges
of corruption lodged against major
corporations an exploding deficit a
middle east in flames the decision still
set off such an uproar that the judge in
the case alfred goodwin felt obliged to
block his own ruling until a higher
court had a chance to hear the case i
really think madeleine would have been
much amused if she'd been around at that
point
thank you
be happy to take some questions or at
least try to answer them
ballpark how many legal cases did she
bring
uh and did she ever represent herself or
did she always even with her law
background or did she always get legal
counsel she brought hundreds of cases
and was responsible for hundreds more
because her organization also had stake
state and local chapters
and she would work with them to bring
cases at one point it's funny in the
early part of her career she was
convinced that the supreme court was the
only way to go because they were the
only ones with courage came out of the
murray decision then later on she kind
of decided well that's not where we want
to go because she thought the tone of
the court was changing so she changed
her focus to start all her cases at the
local level saying we can change things
here and she was very dramatic about
going into she lived in austin texas so
she would go into the austin city
council chambers and demand that they
not pray before you know the session
that this was her feeling that
grassroots kind of behavior was the way
uh to go um so she did bring all of
these cases now
she never took the bar exam and showed
she could never practice law
she could never sign or represent
herself in in in that sense um
she always had attorneys who worked for
her to do it but by
all
measures all references
sometimes angrily by her attorneys she
insisted on writing many of the briefs
herself
she just she would write them and have
them sign it if they tried to change
anything she just sort of tear it out of
their hands and say you're done and that
was the end of it so she did write many
of them or so and they are really
written very i i would recommend many of
the statements that briefs that were
entered in the murray case i think are
the best representation of atheism in
america that you're going to get they're
really very good
so
before i came tonight i was talking with
somebody about your book and they said
madeline murray o'hare gave atheists a
bad name
did she catch much heat from within the
movement
to tone it down and try to become more
you know
mom-and-pop atheism right that's a good
question and it kind of relates back to
maura's question earlier
when she talked about her being as one
of many liberals of the time
her behavior was such that
other liberals
if we can call her a liberal and almost
you know so many people in her movement
rejected her because she was just so
studiedly crude
and vulgar
that people just wouldn't have anything
to do with her at first they were okay
through much of the 60s because that was
kind of a crazy time anyway and
everyone was acting bad uh you know it
was easy in a sense for madeleine she
had lots of cover for her behavior
as you go into the late 70s and in the
80s
in a more
civil time if you want you could take
that as a positive or negative view all
the time um
people really began to just reject her
and whenever she was rejected she tended
to be even more outrageous in her
behavior
one typical scene and it comes you know
she had a great way of mimicking so
people wouldn't miss the point she went
into a bingo
game in a church and did the christ
thing from the new testament went in and
tipped over the tables and started
screaming at the top of her lungs in
order to make the point this was sort of
typical and they did distant that many
people did distance herself from
themselves from her
many times the americans who are
perceived in their own country are
admired and revered abroad for example
woody allen in france marilyn monroe
jerry lewis
roman polanski well he was a european
though how do you have any information
about how she was accepted abroad
chastised here and outsider but was she
respected elsewhere she actually started
the international atheist association
she started herself
and she was she was fairly well regarded
abroad she tended to behave a little
better when she went abroad and i think
that helped too and also
people were less
obsessed
with atheists in the movement abroad so
she could go as she did
to sweden denmark india
france many places and meet with
atheists and no one really cared you
know what they didn't you didn't bring
about the reaction that it did in the
united states so she didn't have that
kind of visibility but she seems to have
been fairly highly regarded enough to be
elected the president of that group for
several years so she did pretty well
abroad
yeah
i have a question to go back to the
diaries um
i'm always interested in documentation
of scholarship and so on how did you
gain access to the diaries
and did you have access to
documents that american atheists keep or
or even documents of her enemies and so
forth
let me answer the first question about
the diaries the diaries were when they
were found were actually sold
at an auction to help pay off the
organization's debts they were purchased
by an attorney
from austin
and it took me about a year to persuade
him
for reasons which i'm still not quite
sure to let me use to read
the diaries and i'm very grateful
i did not intend to include much of
madeline's personal life
in this book i really wanted to look at
atheism in cold war america as an issue
with madeleine as a representation of
that issue
most of the stuff that had been written
about madeleine was pretty
antagonistic
and what i found
from my research most of it was wrong
and that's why i had to in a sense
retreat and i was also
constantly challenged by this idea of
why did she do it and i really took the
diaries to help me figure that out um
also purchased as part of the diaries
were many boxes of personal
documents from her life
which was another one birth certificates
that's another story read the chapter in
the book on birth certificates because
she not she would have one birth
certificate for her son william
which was probably the original one then
she went and had a second one done with
different names
and she did the same thing when her
second son
was born and she was constantly
playing if you will these kinds of games
but the documentation is really there's
quite a bit now as far as american
atheists are concerned um i was not very
successful
they were very protective of her i think
i would have had better luck if she
hadn't disappeared when i was writing
the book
and then they were under such siege
thinking that she'd absconded with the
money that they sort of drew up the the
drawbridge and decided they weren't
going to let anyone
near that documentation however having
said that i it worked out okay because
really there isn't much
personal material an american atheist
there's a lot of literature it's a
wonderful collection on atheism
madeline collected it but there wasn't a
lot of personal papers one thing about
madeleine madeleine wrote everything
down and got it published she had
newsletters she had magazines she had a
radio show then published transcripts in
the radio shows so there wasn't much
that madeleine thought or said that
didn't make it into print so
yes if i can follow on that question uh
was madeleine
spiritual at all did she believe in
spirituality and in examining her
diaries
do you
perceive it all over time any kind of
spiritual or even emotional growth going
on
oh
interesting ending to that question
i didn't detect very much of anything in
terms of a spiritual
understanding there's just nothing there
to deal with she was a committed as she
believed rationalist who just didn't
believe in any kind of spiritual
focus or force in the world
i didn't see very much there at all
and i think if anything
rather than looking at it in terms of
spiritual growth i think if anything
whatever
spiritual
feeling she might have had
um
were lost
over time she died or you know her last
few she was a very very bitter angry
woman at the end
so
okay
you mentioned in europe that she could
become well behaved
i wonder
was there anything endearing or soft
about this woman or was it a show
i mean
understanding a little bit about the
atheist leaders now in the organization
it's a plethora of people being shunned
and splitting off and so it seems more
normal right to me so i was just
wondering is it is this harshness just
part of a show or
i think to a large extent it was
it was it was her performance so that
she would be noticed
but she was a pretty outspoken
woman and
even those who liked her
said that in private she was pretty
tough to be around um
she didn't tolerate fools
well at all and if you said something
she didn't agree with she let you know
there was no question on the other hand
they say she had a fabulous sense of
humor
and
you know could be
fun to be around but those people were
pretty
few and far between i think the
frustration came out you know with her
over the years now
you mentioned europe i think one of the
reasons again i i want to emphasize that
i believe that she was
better behaved in europe is because she
didn't have the spotlight to misbehave
they didn't care that she was there so
there's another atheist group it just
wasn't a big issue
in europe one of the things that kind of
ignited her in the united states was
that she wherever she went the spotlight
was on her and
she would seize it by behaving the way
she did
i suppose she could have engaged in some
outrageous behavior abroad but she just
didn't it wasn't there
in your um reading of her diaries and in
your
discussion of that early period of her
life and her own comment about
i believe it was in one in a later
period of her life where she wondered
to herself why she always wanted to be
angry and and against something
it sounded as though you might be
implying that she was or portraying her
as
a rebel with the cause
by nature that that was her sort of
fundamental personality bent and
further that that perhaps more than
anything more than particular rational
beliefs
might be what was driving her and i just
wonder if you would
comment further on that if that is what
you're implying in the book and if she
ever herself seemed to if that is the
case did she ever herself seem to come
to some kind of an unders
self-understanding
about
what was
making her tick in terms of why she
needed to be
always against something to thrive
yeah clearly there was a rebellious
nature there and she knew it um
i think to a certain extent
anyone in that situation must have had
moments of loneliness when she wished
she wasn't the way that she was because
she led i mean that was a pretty
desperate life i didn't go into it but
the two or three years after the murray
case
um she had to have guards
her house was stoned windows broken
tires slashed her sons were beat up
william was thrown before a bus i mean
it was pretty tough going and i'm sure
that she had moments
when she wished things were different
but i think she she was either worked
into put herself into a situation where
she had nothing else that she could do
but fight back
and one could put a gendered
interpretation of what's going on but i
really do see this as a woman
in the early 50s very bright
very well educated who made some
mistakes and never got over it and
decided rather than apologizing for it
she was going to pull the system down
around her
i really think that was a lot of the
motivation
okay well thank you very much i
appreciate it
[Music]
brian lebeau is author of the atheist
madeline murray o'hare it's published by
new york university press on the web at
nyupress.org
next week on public lives a new
biography of andrew jackson
from andrew burstein